vous parliez des sans culottes de la
france insoumise alexis lacroix allez
vous être le sans culotte de points de
vue que c'est marrant parce que quand il
est question des sans culottes ils se
tournent toujours vers moi alors je
pense qu'il faut que ça c'était un
renault gérard où vous et je sais pas
pendant
je le fais mais après on interrompt
alors c'est vrai que moi sur le principe
si vous voulez j'ai jamais été aussi
vent debout contre l' isf
que certaines voix visions
traditionnelles de la presse de la
droite
après tout bon cette voie là c'est comme
le figaro par exemple par exemple mais
mais comment vous dire c'est un cetain
dissensus kiné qui n'est pas inamicale
maintenant on décide de le supprimer je
pense qu'effectivement c'est plutôt une
bonne mesure et je suis assez d'accord
avec tout ce que dit valérie c'est un
pari c'est le pari de mâcon bon ce qu'il
faut qu'on la compagnie on verra bien ce
que ça donne toute façon des civils et
on est dans le brouillard de l'histoire
on sait pas tout ce que tout ça va
donner peut-être que ça ne donnera rien
peut-être que aura pas de véritable
reprise de l'économie mais concernant la
le l'argument qui vient d'être avancée
par marie je suis d'accord effectivement
on a fait six il est disons au nom d'une
chasse aux riches et d'une
redistribution trop systématique
on a fait s'exiler beaucoup de gens qui
sont des producteurs de richesses et
dont la france d'aujourd'hui a besoin
mais un mot peut-être plus ciblées pour
prendre un peu de 2 comment dire
d'altitude par rapport aux coupures
débat économique
moi ce qui me frappe dans la
l'initiative de françois ruffin de ses
amis du parfum devenu disons d'une coeur
de l'ex parti de gauche et aussi des
socialistes michel lancien guerre des
prix en france du parti socialiste
puisque effectivement michel sapin là
vous êtes dans le coeur de la hollande y
1 ce qui reste de la hollande y cette
initiative la comprends ils sont dans le
rôle encore une fois oublié on peut pas
reprocher à des gens de gauche d'être de
gauche et c'est pas moi qu'il ferait ici
à point de vue néanmoins je crois qu'ils
sont en train de succomber à l'une des
passions fondamental que contre lesquels
d'ailleurs nietzsche qui est un auteur
que vous aimez je pense guillaume avait
mise en garde - savez-vous et cette
passion c'est la passion du ressentiment
voilà je crois qu'il y a aujourd'hui
même si je suis plus réservé que vous
sur la nocivité de l'iace f
je crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui au poste
de commande en france dans de nombreuses
formations politiques mais aussi chez
les journalistes et intellectuels qui a
une passion ressentiment talent et ça
c'est très dangereux parce que ce très
souvent dans l'histoire de la france a
fait le lit non pas de plus de
démocratie mais de davantage de
servitude